hi in this module i'm going to talk
about constraint satisfaction problems
so before we get into constrained
satisfaction problems i just want to
revisit where we've been in the course
we started off with machine learning and
applied to reflex based models such as
classification or regression where the
goal is just to output a single number
or a label
and then we looked at state-based models
in which case the goal was to output a
solution path
and we thought in terms of states
actions and costs or rewards
and now we're going to embark on a new
journey through variable based models
it's going to be a new paradigm for
modeling in which case we're going to
think in terms of variables and factors
so
the heart of variable based models is an
object called a factor graph
we're going to define factor graphs
formally in the next module but for now
let's just try to give some intuition so
a factor graph
consists of a set of variables usually
denoted x1 x2
x3 these are in circles
and a factor graph also contains a set
of factors
usually denoted f1 f2 f3 f4 these are
going to be in squares
so now each factor as you'll notice here
touch is a subset of the variables
and so each factor is going to express
some sort of preference or
determine the relationship that a subset
of variables
has so for example f2 is going to
specify how x1 and x2 are related and f3
is going to specify how x2 and x3 are
related and f4 is going to specify how x
3 is
should be related
the objective of a constraint
satisfaction problem is to find the best
assignment of values
to the variables where we're going to
define what best means in a second
so let's look at an example
of
a problem that can be solved via
constraint satisfaction problem
so here's math coloring
a classic problem here is a
map of australia
we have a number of provinces um seven
to be exact
and each province on western australia
northern territory south australia etc
has to be assigned a color
and the question is how can we color
each province either red green or blue
so that no two neighboring provinces
have the same color so we don't want
western australia and northern territory
to have the same color
so here is one possible solution we can
color western australia red northern
territory green and so on and you can
double check that no two adjacent
provinces have the same color here
so now this is a simple enough problem
that we can just solve it by hand
but as usual we want to ask what are the
algorithmic principles or how do we come
up with something more general to solve
problems such as these
when we encounter them
so before we talk about how we do this
with constraint satisfaction problems i
want to revisit how we might do it with
as a state-based model
um because that's the hammer we have
so um
let's try to cast this as a search
problem
so
we're going to start with initial state
and this state is going to represent
not having assigned any promises any
colors
and then from the state we can take
three possible actions we can grab wa
and assign it red
we can grab wa and assign it green or
you can grab wa and sign it blue
and from each of these
points we can take nt and sign it red
green or blue
red green or blue red green or blue
and you can see here that this is a
search tree as the ones that we have
studied before
and at the very bottom
of the search tree
we have a complete assignment to all the
variables
and each assignment to all the variables
is going to be labeled with either a
zero
if it is inconsistent in other words it
doesn't solve the problem here the
problem is that nt and sa are assigned
the same color that's bad
here's another complete assignment this
is also bad because wna and nt share the
same color
here is an assignment that is good and
you can verify that all the provinces
that are neighboring each other have
different colors and this is going to be
denoted with a weight of one
so in general each
state here represents a partial
assignment of colors to variables
and at the end of the day we can simply
return any leaf that is consistent
for example this one
so this is a perfectly fine way of
solving
this problem
and it goes to show how powerful these
state-based models can be
just to recap the state here is a
partial assignment of colors to
provinces
and from each state an action
assigns the next uncolored province a
compatible color
so what's missing why
are we talking about this when we
already know how to solve it using a
state-based model
well
the question is can we do better than
this and the answer is going to be yes
because there is more problem structure
let me say what i mean by that
so notice that in this problem there's
just a bunch of provinces they need to
get us all assigned colors it doesn't
matter which order i assign
the colors
in other words the variable ordering
doesn't affect correctness
which means that we can
not just stick with a fixed ordering but
we can optimize this ordering and this
is something that inference algorithm
can do for us
and secondly
the variables here are interdependent in
only a local way
and we can decompose the problem
so for example
here we see that
tasmania
is completely separated from the rest of
australia which means that we can
effectively solve the two
separate independent problems separately
and just combine the solutions
and this is as we'll see later
is is great because allow us to really
speed up search
so variable space models
allow us to capture these two additional
pieces of structure
variables based models are umbrella term
that include constraint satisfaction
problems markov networks and bayesian
networks which all of which we're going
to get through over the next few weeks
and the key idea
behind variable space models is we want
to think in terms of variables and in
variables based models a solution to a
problem
is simply an assignment to the variables
and so when you're modeling using
various models we want to set up a set
of variables so that the solution is an
assignment to the variables
and the decisions about how to choose
the ordering of the variables and how to
determine which
variables to set first this is going to
be chosen by the inference algorithm
and the key idea here is that you can
think about variable based models as a
higher level modeling language than
spade based models so here's an
imperfect analogy from programming
languages
so if you were just trying to solve a
problem directly in an ad hoc way that's
kind of like writing an assembly you
just kind of go at it
um
if you were using um
you know c or c plus plus
that's kind of like using state-based
models it gives you a higher level
abstraction which is powerful um and
allows you to save a lot of kind of
headaches
um but variable based models are kind of
even a higher level language like let's
say python
which allows you to think
um
purely in terms of kind of the variables
and the modeling and let the inference
algorithm do more of the work which is
always good because then you can spend
more time doing the fun stuff which is a
lot line
so
i'm going to talk about first constraint
satisfaction problems constraint
satisfaction problems appear in a number
of applications most of which revolve
around large-scale logistics scheduling
and supply chain management so companies
such as amazon have to figure out how to
put packages on vehicles and deliver
them to customers
and at the same time minimizing costs
and meeting all those promise delivery
times
and so here the variables might be the
assignment of packages to vehicles and
the factors would include
travel times and various costs
so ride sharing services such as uber
and lyft also have to
figure out how to best assign drivers to
riders and all these are extensions of a
classical vehicle routing problem
um here's another example from
sports scheduling so the nfl every year
they have to schedule
which teams play which other teams and
when these games are going to be
held
and the schedule here should minimize
travel times between uh of teams
um they have to be a time where they fit
the tv broadcast schedule
um you want to be fair against
across teams and so on
so um other problem scheduling problems
such as these also involve assigning
courses
to slots so the registrar office has a
number of courses that need to be
offered every quarter and they have to
figure out which classrooms to have
these courses in and at what's various
time slots again training off various
constraints like preferences and
availability
so a final application of
constraint satisfaction problems is a
little bit different and this is uh
called the formal verification of
circuits and programs so say you have a
computer program and you want to prove
that this program
is correct let's say the program is
trying to do something like sort numbers
um
so here what you can do is
um normally you would let's say test the
program design a bunch of test cases run
the program and see what happens but
this how do you know for sure that it
works on all inputs
so this is where verification comes in
you want to actually check that it works
for all inputs
um so the way you would set this up is
that you define a set of variables which
correspond to the unknown inputs to the
program
and then the factors encode the program
itself it's going to encode how
execution proceeds line to line
and then you're going to ask the
question whether there exists a program
input that produces an error or an
incorrect result
so unlike the other
applications of csps where you're trying
to find a satisfying assignment
in form of vacation you're trying to
prove the
that no such satisfying
assignment exists because that would
mean an error in your program
so here is a road map for the rest of
the modules on csps
so first we're going to talk about the
definition of a constraint satisfaction
problem and factor graphs do it more
formally then we're going to give a few
examples of csps
then we're going to move over to
inference
we're just going to start by
talking about backtracking search
which is in the worst case exponential
time unfortunately
but but there are a number of ways to
speed up search
taking full advantage of the fact that
we can assign variables in any order we
can look at dynamic order
ordering which we're using heuristics to
figure out which variables assigned
first
and then we're going to look at a
pruning strategy based on our
consistency which is going to allow us
to prune out various values
for each of the variables which are not
promising to explore
so that dynamic ordering can be much
more effective
but in case you're impatient and don't
want to wait a next month of time but
you're satisfied with an approximate
solution you can also do approximate
search so here there's two algorithms
beam search
which is kind of a
extension of the greedy search algorithm
but it's a little bit smarter it's going
to small explore only a small fraction
of the exponentially sized search tree
and local search is going to take an
initial assignment to all the variables
and just trying to improve it by
changing
one variable at a time
all right so that's it for this overview
module
you